if we want to have a conversation about things
that could not be for profit.
[inaudible]
here is obviously on this list and we've been
talking about that for years and that seems
to often be the one that is the most obvious
to the largest number of people.
Although there's still some debate about that
in some political circles.
We can talk about whether education should
be for-profit.
We could talk about whether student lending
should be for profit or certain types of housing
or whatever else.
But increasingly we should be talking about
the Internet, which at this point is really
just a utility which underlies almost everything
we do at this point.
And I'm going to probably end up repeating
this again, but to be a full participant in
2019 society and economy, you effectively
need access to the Internet and probably high
speed Internet at that.
And there are individual towns that have done
what's called municipal broadband, but the
reason that they've done this is that usually
those towns are too small for the big Internet
service providers to want to come in and set
up shop and be the monopoly provider in those
municipalities.
And so I was thrilled to see that 2020 Democratic
presidential candidate and Massachusetts Senator
Elizabeth Warren put out our plan yesterday
for an Internet public option along with her
plan.
By the way, to bring back net neutrality,
and as we've talked about with Medicare for
all a public option is better than nothing.
It may not be the ideal.
And with Internet, it's probably similar,
but I still want to deal with this in detail
today because it could be a really big improvement
over what we have.
And here is Elizabeth Warren's idea.
You pass a federal law to prevent states from
restricting towns that want to do public broadband.
That's number one.
Number two, you do a federal grant for $85
billion, which will be set up to cover 90%
of the costs for utility co-ops, nonprofits,
cities and counties that want to lay fiber
for their own broadband networks.
The federal government will subsidize 90%
of it.
So the city town co-op, whatever, only has
to pay for 10% of it for profit entities would
not be eligible for that grant, which will
push a lot of internet service over to nonprofits
and Co ops and municipalities, which would
be great to qualify for the money.
Uh, the organization that is looking to do
this is going to have to agree to provide
at least one affordable plan for low income
people, a special low price to increase access
to internet, particularly for low income people.
And Meanwhile, yeah, Elizabeth Warren would
also restore net neutrality.
She would appoint commissioners, which would
regulate the internet as a common carrier.
That's a huge, huge thing.
So the breaking news here, which is not breaking
news to lots of people in my audience, is
that both sides aren't the same on many issues
when they are.
I tell you, I've been crystal clear that too
many issues have Republicans and Democrats
basically working together to maintain the
status quo and to reinforce that status quo.
When Democrats require criticism, I'm their
criticizing them, but on lots of important
issues, the two parties are not the same.
One issue we've talked about already, and
could it ever be more clear than now under
Donald Trump rather than Hillary Clinton choosing
judges in the United States Supreme Court
justices and lower level judges.
As we talked about on the bonus show this
week, Donald Trump's power to do that has
had such a significant impact that will be
long lasting.
Donald Trump's judicial choices, more sort
of a celebrated in the Supreme Court, but
also in lower level courts as we've talked
about.
We'll have an effect on the judiciary of the
United States for decades to come.
Hillary Clinton would have been very different
on that.
You might not like her position on whatever,
but Democrats and Republicans drastically
different on that.
It's very similar with the Internet regulation
and net neutrality.
In 2018 all democrats and three Republicans
voted to restore net neutrality.
Okay.
In the house a few months ago, 231 democrats
and one Republican in the House voted to restore
net neutrality and then Mitch McConnell, Republican
Senate majority leader blocked it from even
coming up in the Senate at all.
So we need to support candidates with the
right views on this issue.
I love that Elizabeth Warren, I've made no
secret.
I think it's great that she's been running
one of the most substantive campaigns of 2020
so far, slowly but surely creeping up in the
polls.
And she did it again in a couple of recent
polls, which I don't have time to talk about
today, but maybe we'll deal with on Monday.
She has been doing that with substantive policy
proposals.
No cheap shots, no, you know, debate, kill,
shot attempts the way some other candidates
have been doing just policy, detailed policy,
which she's increasingly good at explaining
in clear and direct terms.
And that's a really good thing.
So bottom line in 2019, you essentially need
Internet and, and I would argue not just internet
but high speed Internet to fully participate
in society and in the economy period flat-out.
Thus it should be a public utility.
Anything short of that falls short of the
goal.
But these public option, uh, programs like
what Elizabeth Warren is suggesting here are
absolutely great ideas.
I think that legally they are quite simple.
So when Warren talks about, oh, I want to
pass a wealth tax, uh, okay, you could like
the idea, not like the idea, think it's the
right way or the wrong way to reduce inequality,
think that inequality is an issue, but legally
it will be very complex to get a wealth tax
pass.
That's just the reality.
This public option Internet plan and the re
and statement of net neutrality would not
be legally complicated.
It can be complicated in the terms of lobbyists,
in terms of lobbyist opposition and massive
ad dollars lobbying, just average people to
be against it and massive lobbying dollars
lobbying politicians to be against it.
That will be complicated, but when it comes
to the legality of doing it, there are not
constitutional issues that are not commerce
issues or any other issues that I am aware
of.
It's merely the political will and that's
why this is absolutely fantastic.
Let me know what you think about these and
other net neutrality and Internet utility
ideas.
I'm on Twitter at d pacman.
The show is on twitter@davidpakmanshowandthedavidpakmanshowisnowontwitchattwitch.tv
slash David Pakman.
Hope you'll follow us there and subscribe
twitch prime if you have an Amazon prime@thedavidpakmanshow